[Musique]
depuis le 1er février
cette oeuvre inspirée du personnage de
la commedia dell'arte arlequin ont pris
place dans la salle d'exposition de la
maison elsa triolet aragon une
exposition intitulée art lucky nahd est
signée par l'artiste péruvienne olga
luna l'exposition mêle des oeuvres qui
avait été créée dans la dernière période
dans les cinq six dernières années et en
même temps toute une série d'offres qui
sont des créations qui ont été réalisés
ici même à la maison elsa triolet aragon
en amont notamment à travers le biais
d'ateliers quand il y eu avec le ghana
et qui auront lieu également pendant
toute la durée de l'exposition puisque
nous allons organiser une série
d'ateliers autour notamment de cette
question du masque couleurs contrastées
formes géométriques
l'exposition confronte des créations de
l'artiste de nature différente des
peinture en acrylique des masques en
plâtre ou encore des pliages ce qui est
intéressant aussi voyez c'est que elle
propose à travers ses pliages d'autres
regards sur les objets par exemple vous
avez la même photographique d'une
photographie de son fils en l'occurrence
équipes liées de différentes façons mais
on a l'impression que ce sont des
photographes et qui sont différentes et
oui ça interroge un petit peu sur ce que
ces clubs est ce que c'est que le regard
de celui qui regarde une heure durant
les vacances scolaires d'hiver la maison
elsa triolet aragon propose des ateliers
de fabrication de masques pour les
enfants l'exposition elle se poursuit
jusqu'au 10 mai